uh let's say if you
end up very unhappy or maybe you're just
like
something can just switch you know maybe
you can just like oh i don't like him
anymore would you stay married
to him for the rest of your life you're
not sexually attracted you don't like
he's just not funny anymore you just
don't like him anymore do we do we have
kids yeah if we have kids it's not about
me anymore so you would rather ha see
your children grow up in a home where
parents are sleeping in separate
bedrooms they don't talk they don't have
they don't kiss i would rather see my
kids grow up at home where they're at
every statistical advantage rather than
statistical disadvantage because if the
father is out of the home that you put
that kid at risk why because life is not
easy like it's you you might think you
know as a woman like oh my kid's gonna
be fine your child is just another human
being in this world the world is going
to show your kids that they're at a
disadvantage and we were talking about
it because we were talking about mental
health the other day and i was saying
like mental health isn't a thing in my
family like we're all just happy people
and she she says to me that's because
you had both parents in the home